definitely not staring right of your
dick thanks man I would stare at your
dick but you don't have any dick so
congratulations this is why we pick
games
bending at the waist so anyway there's a
story to this go talk to that farmer
oh my god go outside and take a look you
gotta kill all those creatures out there
I don't know a lot about the game but
why the hell is he pinned to the wall
with the legs well I lost my leg and I
was like how am I gonna stand up
pitchfork and I was like look just pay
me into the wall with all those pigs out
there where am I gonna be going anyway
right right you know what I'm talking
about in a second oh my god don't figure
when he gets excited also I like I would
the blue of his jeans this smeared on
his leg oh is it oh yeah it's were
painted on it was violently ripped off
his legs got his leg got bitten off at
that point and then the lips of whatever
bit he was wearing above the knee blew
smears on there that explains it
perfectly yeah and if you shoot him
he gets actually shooting pigs they're
out here somewhere
oh isn't that it's not a little on the
nose killing cops at a time like this in
our country oh wow man okay friend yeah
unless you help so how hard are these
things - oh my god it's not dying okay
oh my god that's actually like a brand
page of the murder page oh my god
oh please not like this oh goodness that
is horrific tip good job yeah I I
appreciate that I guess I'm starting to
think that maybe this isn't what we were
supposed to be doing in this also hi
hello everybody
we're playing blood and bacon all the
sprints well yeah look at how you look
when you sprint the skeleton walk cycle
is just really stupid because you're
you're just picking your knees up you're
not actually going forward at all you're
just kind of like how do i sprint again
slower
oh it's toggle goggles oh that's stupid
we gotta get to the formula yeah you
gotta simulate the effect of your
acceleration though on your body let me
show you yeah watch gotta go fast see
wasn't that funny hey I can't hear his
very important dialogue oh my god he
follows you his head turns and follows
you and I know it's really disturbing
what's that I think you mean it's really
disturbing I was just reading that let
me do the reading
wait it's changeable everyone
appreciates Futurama references that's
actually quite impressive yeah look how
much I [ __ ] up the physics on those
chains yeah yeah oh farmers more say
those creatures multiplied overnight
they just came back wait wait so
those zombie pigs are they zombies
because that's a big question here just
very excitingly multi-coloured pigs yeah
and apparently they're sex-crazed too
because somehow they reproduced
overnight and I don't know how that
works but I don't think again aren't you
a professional youtuber that's so cool
think again
starting on the audio and going down
good work everybody
good work I blame you blame me what did
I do
I did nothing I'm just trying to be a
cool guy that's why you need to clean
yourself they get to shoot it up the ass
to make it explode what okay you just
I'll distract it you shoot it hurry
guys yeah all right I'm gonna get that
one running around I mean that's true to
every living creature everyone knows
that it's the one weak spot right yes
like in Zelda the big glowing gas is the
weak version of the word the explosion
comes from Latin is it yes well I must
have missed something drink from what
because it's either the pig or that
water spout just be careful you don't
hit their self-destruct button on the
way up they're just good old f1 f3 to
change oh my god their side camera I'm
gonna play inside camera okay from now
on me also let's talk to this guy
anymore
there we go so we need to shove dead
pigs into that meat grinder
okay going to the side view here I've
been inside view man this is the only
way to live anymore is that the camera
doesn't tilt up and down even when you
aim up and yeah also I sure hope there's
something in front of me to shoot can
you see me
I keep seeing flashes of you wait oh god
it's coming oh god they're somewhere in
front of me Oh God Oh mark oh they're
coming this was a mistake I'm committed
Oh God
are we still playing inside the camera
because I you abandoned I got one or you
got one may I know who could tell oh no
I'm out of animal you run out of AKM oh
hell [ __ ] [ __ ] cue to change oh god
[Music]
what does this guy hold his wrists like
this with the pistol I'm just too
fascinated in my own walk cycle to care
about anything else just like his
running coach and I kept telling him
lift with your knee you said he just
never commit to anything into the sky my
strategy has turned into run backwards
yeah and so assume that they're chasing
me and just shoot straight away from
these are the [ __ ] I'm stuck on a
fence dude I'm stuck I'm stuck
holy [ __ ] wait I keep finding the
boundaries of the thing oh no keep
getting stuck everywhere where's that
goddamn water fountain that there
talking about yeah like we're gonna find
that [ __ ] I'll find it I'll find it
eventually I know it was behind the
white house so I just got to look for
some white and then I'll be good
well if you hope I guess if you hope
left it's kind of like running forward
so I've got the hacks the mechanic the
way that your character though there's
still 10 pigs left I'm pretty sure
they're all on me it's okay I found you
like this exactly like this I'm so
almost dead right now yeah I got it how
do I I have absolutely lost track of
where the thing was - I got whoa whoa
Nellie okay I found it oh there's a
bunch of [ __ ] pigs over here whoo
he's right in front of me that's why I
look familiar they just ripped off a
left for dead that's what they did
whoo oh I'm stuck in a pig corpse if you
could come find me and help me you
better not go first person you better
not say [ __ ] I know aiming at right now
oh my god I'm about to die so hope
you're doing okay oh I'm dead I died oh
it's only there's zero left you have to
go talk to the farmer now
I gotta restart it today that's press
tab key I didn't even know that we have
stats wait hang on let's see how I did
eight percent success rate three a
success metal so that my skeleton man
can rock out
[Music]
I'm sure that'll look good in post
all right fine [ __ ] this oh we used to
start over at the beginning of day three
yeah it's lovely
great checkpoint system something about
a meat grinder something about it
yeah did you know there's a meat grinder
out there you could grind your meat whoa
whoa we're secret item I don't have any
secret items what are their secrets in
this game wait mark I'm a secret I say
we do a full completion how do you do
that
and the episode and then we'll do a full
completionist of this game it's amazing
this game is incredible Oh tiny pig okay
the masterpiece it is look up good this
game is all right so solo is happening
to the pig on top of the meat grinder I
think it's a good ground wait okay
shoot the glowing buttons Oh Oh Joe
jingle mujinju
bring pieces of pig over there yeah you
could mail a them into it all right yeah
sake for some reason Oh got to turn this
on
okay it's going it's going
ammo yeah this is awesome I love this
this is really it's a master it's a
masterful piece dude 490 weight 89 cents
can I go into the meat grinder you don't
have any meat dude you know I don't want
to be discriminatory but you really
don't have any meat on you that was
pretty quick
wait look click look at me all right
don't look thanks me I'm gonna melee the
[ __ ] out all these pigs okay get over
there you slighty corpse I think we're
we done I think we're just supposed to
go talk to the farmer yeah but we can we
can shove all these [ __ ] into
the grinder if we want No
all right I guess so we go talk to the
weird stabby douchebag yeah yeah yeah
wait mark mark I've known one of the
secret things in the game okay I'm on
the way all right all right so if you
look right here right here mm-hmm
like right there yeah again I'm looking
at out it's an outline of a gun right
right is there I bet if you stand on my
head and you go up there and you and you
press X at it I bet it's a secret gun I
I can't stand on I think you're
bullshitting me but I want to believe
you I feel like I'm pretty sure I saw
this as an easter egg
why don't you jerk yourself off a little
bit after you wipe your face because you
know I just want to feel good let me do
my thing
well you don't have anything to jerk off
you kind just Pat you're empty void
where your stomach would be well there's
a whole human before though like it
habits you know like I had something
down there probably yeah okay but I mean
I don't think ghosts penis is a thing
you're like ghosts you know ghosts limbs
phantom phantom penis sorry
not ghosts penis that's a movie I
watched last night don't worry about it
yeah that whole gun thing was absolutely
made up I was pretty sure I just I
wanted to give you the benefit of the
doubt there I'm finishing this thanks
man old yet yeah all right all right
he's too excited about this pig murder
okay all right I'm honest about this
let's do a full completionist of this
game I'm sure it can only get better
let's do all right so thank you
everybody so much for watching I know
you didn't ask for it but get ready
we're gonna play through this whole
goddamn game so yeah yeah so thanks
again thank you Bob for joining me and
as always we'll see you
Thank You Marc Marc Marc Marc Marc Marc
here to wreck [ __ ]